so I'm here with the cameraman this day
so we're here we're just waiting it's 2
p.m. they run a bit late
I will quite easy smoke well I've got a
suit [ __ ] that's why would you why would
you do that cuz I I did thou on the
scene
yadi yadi the nurse Alexander Steve
she wants to shake your hand again you
guys all et al e TV so you guys don't
know this go ahead poor Gordon this data
you see you guys when they're harassing
Muslims in general yeah he's fine the
Happy Days harassing Muslims but when
the same is done to them I won't even
harassing him were just here waiting for
them
look at how they're panicking they're
gonna we're gonna do that for another
exit
how does it feel nothing when you're
going to people sticking a camera in
their face you know when I hit her ass
that one's gonna have a decent
conversation and ask him a few questions
because poor building is being done for
sexual harassment charges
Jada has been trying to bribe the lady
the polish lady who is pressing the
charges thomas mayor we know job
Djokovic's joke offices kill anyone in
shot in Britain first and John
broomfield is one of their members in
Brighton and he was charged for plotting
to blow up the Brighton West and he was
called 173 so in these images of babies
and children and not only that one of
their followers
I think a couple of days ago tried to
run into a run a man who claimed that he
followed brain first and basically tried
to run over some Asian guy yeah and
before he beat he beat his wife and then
he came out I said I'm gonna go and do
something to these Muslim cetera and he
tried to run somebody over so this is
all coming from them and you can see
they have the same ideology same
thinking as Isis yeah same thing preach
hate and anything people get hurt and
when the confronted Paul starts crying
okay
mr. gold
I've been again a few more people to
come to distract us or use the security
and in might you never get physical
we've had a physical bar when I hit but
I we need to just ask some questions and
get some answers
- we wanted
right
yes this is anyway that's that's we've
got intelligence oh you asked the
question we gave the answer well thank
you think can we ask more questions yeah
what's going ok what no I call them non
violent extremists yeah yeah because
I'll see what Isis does with a pretreat
and you have innocent people dying yeah
because of them they brainwash evil
these guys do the same thing they go out
there this time is to take homework in
everybody only wasn't we have this
Martin is my original Hodja by Isis and
yeah so I'm here to challenge you guys
because of you guys any sane people have
died since we probably got in it
innocent wasn't in run over look what's
happening terrorist attacks why did
well she wrote site she's
right yeah yeah she's just great
yeah we well sushi that's we play yeah
what's painful 9ic mean dramatic noise
dude yeah yeah his pictures playing oh
she's playing crying over what could be
one sweetie
oh yeah no she looks quite distressed
there sure she's trying
new alimony Saints alive Nellie no
basically they're not coming out and
read go Oscar for crying we're just
going to the bathroom
in the back this way the thing didn't
exist but if you see them coming out
from
ha ha you stay here boy dinner we're
waiting things comfortable
Hey
Jaina wedding on some questions
get Robin Padilla get questions
any you see these colors their cupboards
account
coward
you see
guys power data so that you know
something
J no I don't wanna talk
[Music]
so as you can see guys didn't speak by
spoke volumes
spoke volumes we're just trying to say
look stop the violence
yeah because we would want to locate her
not you you just talk talk talk somebody
gets brainwashed runs off of Muslims or
non-muslims yeah whose game her look in
her innocent kids watch they die because
of you because you want someone in your
pocket no no first stop to that and we
all challenge
Taylor you claiming things about my
religion my religions been hijacked by
you and Isis and Tommy Robinson the rest
yet and the upsets yeah cuz you're going
on tough I named my religion and say
this what it teaches
so this is the reason why I came here
today just a little discussion you was
here I was here for hours
oh we wanted a discussion what do they
do they wait she goes there starts
crying crying for here to talk and then
they run off in the back there are
Muslims in the UK there is Steve is
there Muslims only extremists backs into
extremist comment or different colors in
fact we had one today yet there are
extreme mood I believe the bridge public
what these guys do this is a gap in the
market so they using the genuine concern
of the public to say you know what yes
this is what they teach and well he has
to fight that no maybe you're an
extremist as much as Isis we've asked
the reason we're not just here for them
I'm here to combat Islamic extremist as
well yeah if we could get hold of them
because we don't know we're there we can
track these guys down but then we don't
know where they are are they locked up
or whatever we're hit on the walk under
issues becoming the cross the envelope
you should be lovely people yet they
don't go around doing this yet so as you
can see I'm a Muslim as well I don't go
around doing one it's not make sure you
stir so DC the British public Muslim and
non-muslim order one site the extremist
Islamic extremist and these far-right
wish the wrong side thank you so much we
shake my hand yeah goes bad you know
what is just that even beautiful Jews
used to see
and the Saints were Muslim woman doesn't
want to check because you see noise
because I'm a good because I'm a [ __ ]
family